Aaron is with us in Ohio assuming I
pushed the right button there's Aaron is
in Ohio hi Aaron how are you doing baby
how are you doing better than I deserve
what's up okay my question here my wife
and I would currently we have about
$24,000 total deaths we make about
65,000 last year um we are with $20,000
on a car our second car we're upside
down on about $7,000 and my question is
is should we once we get our smaller
debts out should we try to sell this car
or keep it my wife wants to keep it I
don't want to keep it so you just don't
want to keep it because of the debt well
not so much today I I think we really
rushed into it and I think we got a bad
deal I think I really do I think you
bought I think you bought a car that's
stupid yeah absolutely I agree but I
don't know if that I don't know if that
is a reason to sell it right now here's
the thing you would never buy a car
again the rest of your life when the
total of all the vehicles that you own
are more than half your annual income
and you were probably pretty close when
you bought this car because this car put
you right up the edge now though the car
is only worth 13 so it only solves a
portion of your debt problem you still
got the $7,000 worth of debt if you sell
it right right and you got to get
another car so it's not going to move
the needle that much on getting you out
of debt but we do need to both be able
to join hands and look at the thing as
it sits in the driveway and go that was
one of the dumbest things we've ever
done we will never do that again and we
need to be able to do that as a couple
both of you you've done that but she
needs to do that too
so that you never have to have a fight
about this again it's like now if we
have the cash we will buy a car
otherwise we are not buying the car for
the for the rest of
she's mrs. dumb idea but she just liked
the car more than I do
well you decided because it just like
screams like the screams that your your
stupid every time you see it yeah yeah
that's what I mean I've owned stuff like
that too it just it just it every time I
look at it it reminds me I did something
dumb you know
and I get that but I think I think in
this case you roll up your sleeves and
you pay this debt off you guys get on a
really really tight budget and beans and
rice rice and beans you don't need to
see the inside of a restaurant unless
you're working there you need to have a
big garage sale you need to sell so much
stuff the kids think they're next and
let's roll up our sleeves and get this
debt cleared up I think you can pay off
$20,000 with a debt making 60 in about
18 months but it's a beans and rice no
life budget and then you can do this a
couple thousand dollars a month makes us
go away in a year and that may mean you
pick up extra job or some overtime or
some sawdust or you make it all go away
in a year if you did that but 60 over 24
after you pay taxes and eat you not got
much left to to do that much faster than
about eighteen months and that's really
tight that's a tight budget to do that